nos dan las funciones f x2 x cuadrada
más 15 x 8 gtx igual a x al cuadrado más
10 x 16 y nos piden encontrar efe sobre
g de x o bien encontrar
efe / g de x y seguramente por la forma
en la cual lo estoy diciendo ya te has
de estar imaginando qué quiere decir
esta función en efecto la función efe /
g de x
efe / g de x por definición es la
función que aquí evaluada en x es igual
a efe de x entre g de x muy bien con
esto en mente ya podemos sustituir f&g
para ver que obtenemos efe lo voy a
poner en color verde entonces en el
numerador nos quedaría 2x cuadrada más
15 x menos 8 esta expresión de acá y en
el denominador nos quedaría g de x
y gx es igual a x al cuadrado más 10 x
más 16 muy bien podríamos dejar esta
expresión así sin embargo vamos a
simplificar la un poquito con un poco de
suerte el numerador y el denominador
comparten factores y entonces se puede
ver pues un poco más bonita vale bueno
con esto en mente dejar de intentar
factorizar el numerador o sea 2x
cuadrada 2x cuadrada más 15 x menos 8 es
una expresión de grado 2
una expresión cuadrática podríamos
utilizar la fórmula cuadrática pero
déjame intentar factorizar la con el
método de agrupamiento es decir vamos a
intentar encontrar dos números que
multiplicados nos den 2 x menos 8 es
decir que multiplicados nos den menos 16
y que sumados nos den 15 que nos en 15
estamos haciendo esto porque el
coeficiente principal no es 1 entonces
pues por eso no basta con que el
producto sea menos 8 vale te tiene que
ser menos 16
entonces qué números pueden funcionar
pues saber uno tiene que ser positivo y
otro negativo para que el producto sea
negativo y uno tiene que ser más grande
que 15 y otro más pequeño que 15
entonces con un poco de suerte le
pegamos y segundo el 16 y el menos 1
funciona si 16 x menos 1 es menos 16 16
menos uno es 15 excelente entonces la
idea de factorizar por agrupamiento es
que ahora este 15 lo podemos partir en
16 x menos x
déjame hacer esto nos quedaría 2x
cuadrada 2x cuadrada más 16 x menos x
menos 8
muy bien y ahora el chiste es reconocer
un factor común de estos dos términos y
de estos dos términos entonces vamos a
sacar de estos dos términos de los
primeros 2 1 2 x 2x que nos quedaría
adentro aquí nos quedaría x y aquí nos
quedaría más 8 si hacemos 2x por x 8
regresamos a esta expresión y de modo
similar estos dos términos les podemos
actualizar un -1 podemos hacer menos uno
y aquí hay que multiplicar multiplicamos
una vez más por x más 8 muy bien de
hecho justo este es el punto de
factorizar por agrupamiento que ahora
tenemos un x + 8 y otro x + 8 que
utilizando la propiedad distributiva
pero al revés podemos actualizar de la
siguiente manera como 2x menos 12 x
menos 1 x x más 8
excelente x x8 entonces con esto ya
podemos factorizar el numerador nos
queda deja lo pongo con el color verde
nos queda 2x menos 1 x x más 8 ok y
ahora eso lo tenemos que dividir entre
el denominador y el denominador también
es una expresión cuadrática podemos
factorizar la col con la fórmula
cuadrática pero como esta si es esta
expresión si tiene coeficiente principal
1 entonces vas a encontrar dos números
que multiplicados nos den 16 y que
sumados nos den 10 entonces pues qué
números son esos 8 por 12 16 8 + 2 son
10 entonces podemos poner aquí x 2 x x +
8 y esto es tan fantástico nada más
déjame ponerlo en el color morado
entonces esto es x 2 x x + 8 y te digo
que está fantástico porque arriba y
abajo apareció este x + 8 que ahora
podemos cancelar
entonces la idea es que éste
este los vamos a cancelar este con este
pero ojo hay que tener mucho cuidado
para de veras cancelarlo debemos de
cuidar que x sea distinto de menos 8x no
sea menos 8 vale si x es igual a menos 8
entonces estamos dividiendo entre 0 y
esta expresión no está definida si los
cancelamos así sin tener cuidado aquí
obtendríamos 2x menos 1 y aquí
dividiríamos entre x más 2 y si no
ponemos esta restricción de que x sea
distinto de menos 8 esta función no
puede ser la misma que ésta porque ésta
no está definida en menos 8 pero está
así vale entonces hay que cuidar eso
entonces ya nada más para acabar déjame
reescribir la expresión entonces lo que
obtuvimos es que efe entre g de x la
función
efe / g evaluada en el punto x es igual
a 2 x menos uno
/ x 2 x 2 coma con la condición de que x
sea distinto de menos 8 porque si x
porque si no le pedimos esta condición
de acá entonces estas funciones no
pueden ser iguales porque la de la
izquierda no está definida en menos 8 y
la de la derecha sí bueno hasta aquí le
dejo a este ejercicio nos vemos hasta la
próxima